asteroids are important for two reasons
they contain lots of valuable natural
resources and they have the power to
kill everything on earth it's for both
of these reasons that nASA has created
the asteroid hundred contest you can win
up to 35 thousand dollars if you can
come up with a new and improved
algorithm to track and follow asteroids
currently NASA's only able to track
about 1% of all the asteroids in our
solar system that means there could be a
world killing asteroid headed for us
right now and we wouldn't even know it
and we've had a couple of close calls
recently in 2013 a rogue space rock
missed us by only a few thousand miles
closer than some communication
satellites and on the very same day an
asteroid streaked into the atmosphere
over Russia and exploded with the force
of an atomic bomb that asteroid was just
50 feet across an asteroid one mile wide
cue the aerosmith because things are
about to get all cataclysmic hence the
asteroid hunter contest obviously it
would be better to find these things
before there is a planet threatening
event but it's important to note that
NASA's partner in the contest Planetary
Resources is hunting asteroids for an
entirely different reason prophet turns
out that many asteroids are loaded with
precious minerals which means that
crowd-sourced asteroid detection is not
only a good way to prevent mass
extinction but also a good way to make a
buck